hey david why do most white people vote
for republicans
this is uh this is a complex question
that requires a lot of different
um exploration and the answer is not
um because white people are merely
racist and they vote for republicans
that that's not if that's what you
believe it's overly simplistic
there are of course elements of racism
uh but that that's really not what this
is about so it is true that when you
look at current polling and you slice
and dice
it demographically by age by race by
income you know all these different
things by education
donald trump is winning among men by not
not by a huge margin
donald trump is winning among white
voters
and donald trump is winning among
uneducated voters the more education you
have the more likely
you are to support joe biden the answer
to
a lot of the white support for
republicans
actually is religion and i want people
to be
very very carefully uh understanding
what it is that i'm saying here
white evangelicals overwhelmingly vote
for republicans
white non-evangelicals are pretty split
between the democratic and the
republican party so to say it another
way
were it not for white evangelicals
the republican party would not have the
advantage it has
among white voters and this is why you
might
see american politics and you say
there's more support for abortion today
than there has been at any time since
roe v wade
uh and yet they st the republicans still
kowtow to being against abortion
and they still uh try to play you know
they trump speaking at the march for
life and all of this different stuff
the reason why is that they are
dependent on the white evangelical voter
not only for votes but also for
donations
evangelicals are just over a third of
white voters
okay so you've got all white voters a
third of white voters are evangelical
they voted for trump roughly four to one
80 to 20.
other white voters went for hillary
56 to 44 according to exit polls against
trump in 2016.
so when you slice and dice the
electorate you
you start to understand that the
analysis that white people prefer
republicans
it's not really getting at the core of
the issue which in this particular case
is religiosity now
any time you look at these distinctions
uh you have to be able to
separate causation versus correlation
okay
i don't know exactly how that affects
the the white voter element of it
but for example with education you see
that people without a college degree
are the most likely educationally to be
voting for trump
people with a college degree support joe
biden by by a pretty big margin
people with a postgraduate degree
support joe biden by an even higher
margin the more education you have the
more likely you are to support biden
over trump
i actually believe that is causal i
think that
education as a process makes you less
likely to be bamboozled by
stupid talking points from trump like i
know all about trade and i will fix it
the more educated you are the more
likely you are to realize trump knows
nothing about trade and he's not going
to fix it and you shouldn't fall for it
so
that is causal to me with some of these
other things
religion race whatever
i think that we have to explore whether
the correlations have a causal component
that's sort of not
really what we were taking head on uh
but that's the situation yes
white voters support republicans but
were it not for white evangelicals
that support would be very much in
question